you'll be labeled bigger and taller and
this and that
anyway um i've said what i had to say uh
he just called me right now actually
okay uh i couldn't answer because we're
getting ready for this
um i would talk to him and you know i'm
not sure how you know hamdillah from the
brothers i guess he got my number it's
okay i i
i appreciate the fact that he's trying
to call me we'll talk like men to men
and that's it no problem called you
right
yeah yeah just now
my children how to knit i learned to
knit when i was six years old and i
remember
the moves in round out and off
in round out and off now my kids are
learning
i just got them a set of knitting
needles and some huge wool
and we said let's go for it mashallah
you know minky and zinji can have a
little blanket or two
and say okay women is this sexy for you
and the women are saying
my husband doesn't have the
libido the strength why because he's
knitting man
i want to ask the women do you want your
husband to do that i want to ask the man
do you want you and your boys to do that
our chefs are teaching us to knit okay
what's the objective of this video
why do we not ride the horse or shoot
the arrow
or go for swimming go for a run or some
of the things that are in the sun of
manhood the brussels seems described as
coming on a horse with no saddle with a
sword
around his neck i'm using a little
knitting thing
i think most people watching this
probably know who muftimank and alidawah
are however i think a lot of people are
not familiar with
brother gabriel and therefore i think he
might be getting a bad rap
for those of you who might think that oh
he's just you know some guy who
uh refuted mufti mink or something like
that look this brother has been putting
in
work giving dawah for years and years
he's traveled the muslim world working
for different communities and right now
his main focus has been
family counseling it's been this topic
of
gender roles of men being men being
masculine women being feminine
and addressing the whole dynamics of men
and women relationships and the family
structure so this is his field this is
what he's really been focusing on you
know i lecture with mufti
all around the world i've been working
with brother gabriel which many of you
might not know
since 2011. so for more than 10 years
we've been working together
and like i said i love both of them
dearly so is his response to mufti
justify what he was saying and is
knitting really that big of a deal so
you know brother muffet he's more of a
soft-spoken you know nice guy comes off
like this
has a huge impact on the people he's
doing a fantastic job michelle brother
gabe he's trying to keep it real he's
coming you know he's coming at you'll be
hard
a bit harsh one of the questions that
brother gabe is asking what is your
objective of making this video he has an
objective and i understand where he's
coming from i don't agree
that it was a good video from the
masculinity side and also from the side
as a public figure and to be fair this
is a serious problem
that we are facing and he's someone who
has experience as a principal in in
muslim schools you know around the world
and you see that the identity the
manhood
of these young boys who are going up
it's been taken away from them because
of what the media and the social media
platforms have been brainwashing our
children
therefore he felt that when someone of
the status of mustimi came out with
something
that doesn't support you know being a
man being an alpha male someone who's a
proper graduate
and just think about how many things you
didn't know that we just talked about
now right
and i'll think about how much more there
is that you probably don't know because
you grew up in a society where they
don't talk about these things and
they're shunned
they shouldn't be shunned because if
they're shuns then you won't have good
intimacy then your marriage breaks apart
then your family breaks apart and
the community breaks apart it's not good
it starts here
and with that being said may allah bless
you all and grant us
good spouses and children who will be
the coolness of our eyes and allow us to
be leaders for the righteous people
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
t3m podcast
it's your host fired and we're joined
with our two special guests brother
gabriel and brother greg assalam alaykum
it was a miracle that we we aligned our
three time zones to get all of us on
this call alhamdulillah we got it to go
but there's a lot going on in this world
today we got some
stuff going on with uh the president of
the united states
bombing the hell out of syria we got
mufti meink
uh who apparently thinks chickens quack
but
again it is what it is all due respect
him you know here's the thing we live in
a society today
and for people that don't really follow
with what i'm saying we'll get to it in
a bit
we live in a society where you know
people want
you know to brainwash us and and think
that chickens do quack
right and we also live in a society
where chickens can now go through
surgery
to be able to quack but the reality is
chicken shouldn't quack
and as as men as salafi as muslim men we
need to be
apparent and overtly obvious that we are
not ducks
but society wants us to be able to look
like ducks and not be like ducks now
before yeah yeah you got you got to
bring up the speed on this what's this
about
chickens quacking what what's what's the
story
all right so that's the thing with the
internet he's right you have this tick
tock attention span
if somebody says something even if it's
someone like brother gabriel who's just
been doing positivity for the muslim
community
he gets cancelled he gets called out um
i think it was a brother named ali dawa
who made a video response to him pretty
big on uh
tiktok and youtube so brother gabriel
i'll let you just go in with that
yes
well i mean it's not that complicated
you know it's just that
um you know there's some guys out there
who are just not
talking about the real things the real
issues and
i think this one just kind of drove me
off the
edge for a bit because recently i've
been dealing with a lot of kids who are
turning gay and you know if you
dig in deep as to why either the fathers
are not there or they've been abused or
they're addicted to porn or
uh you know they've been emasculated
from a very young age to believe that
you know you can be a princess if you
want you can be this if you want you can
be whatever
what you want you know what i mean so um
it's it's not just
it's not a joke it's not a challenge on
youtube or facebook debate or as people
think
you know being somehow maybe uh jealous
of followers
subhanallah so many things have been put
out there by so many theories
this is about bottom line is that the
muslim ummah
and humans in general being attacked
and they are made weak
okay specifically the ones that are
really targeted
are men males okay
and you can see it now california and
put a law where you cannot separate toys
by gender you get
fined one thousand as a new law right
now that if you
stop your children if they want to take
um
blockers for puberty that you will get
your children taken away by children a
society whatever you know
a social worker i mean where is the
world going
uh mattel came with you know this gender
by gender
dolls just recently i posted about that
what is going on what is going on
this is not you know the conspiracy
theory
this is a problem so i work as a school
principal thousands of kids run through
me
okay i work also as an educational
consultant going around the muslim
schools and muslim world
and i deal with families and children
and the families
are complaining that their kids are
losing themselves their masculinity the
boy specific
sitting getting chubby playing games
no movement and starting to do feminine
things you know starting to do more and
more feminine
things um sit down shut up
just listen play a game be on your
tablet
uh you know eat some whatever food
and that's it you know what i mean but
for anyone that's kind of still not on
speed or
you know the two of the brothers we got
right here mufti bank who is you know a
very well
followed you know in the in the
spotlight of islam dawah
channels um and you know people look up
to him he makes good heartfelt videos
he makes good reminders i'm sure you
guys are familiar with it
and he he made a video a few weeks ago
or a few years ago i believe it was just
in the past about
you know if my wife wants me to move
left i'm going to move left i'm not
going to you know ask why she wants me
to move left if she wants me to move
right
when i'm sitting down i'll move right so
what it makes her happy
no i might you know so what it makes me
a chicken no i might even quack quack
and that's that's that's where the whole
you know theme came from my wife were to
phone me now
and tell me move to the left i'd move to
the left even if there's no place
out of love that's it so what if that
makes her happy it makes her happy
you know people might say this guy is a
chicken i don't mind being called a
chicken
i'll even quack quack for you a little
bit as long as she's happy
mashallah yeah if that's what makes your
marriage let it be
we all made a response video to that
saying that okay
you know all due respect you know we're
not going to negate any of the work
you've done for the maxim mumba for the
community
but these types of you know things
phrases that come out of your mouth they
will have repercussions
your brother romani so you saw the video
by mufi
bless him he's a good brother he's doing
a lot of good work right but i believe
again that sometimes some of the things
that he says are just
not realistic and they cause some issues
among
especially when he speaks about marriage
i just think that he's just not
i don't know it's just not his field you
know you should stick to like
encouragements and reminders for
brothers and sisters you know about the
dean
when it comes to marriage i think this
is causing problem like a video like
this oh if my wife calls me i'm just
she tells me to move left i'm gonna move
left and she wants me to you know call
me a chicken i come on man what has
happened to masculinity
what has happened to manhood what has
happened
where we used to be leaders and women
were happy because that because we are
real men not chickens
and chickens don't quack by the way you
know so
i mean what is going on right and [ __ ]
on is not going to work
you know directly it's going to happen
over generations right it's just like
you know 30 40 years ago you would look
at a guy with earrings and be like okay
that's gay
right then slowly you know you started
with one then start with two
the whole thing is like where do you
draw the line that's where brother
gabriel was going to and
now uh multiman you know all due respect
to him he made
a video on instagram about knitting
right and he's like i used to learn when
i was knitting when i was six
i tell my kids how to knit and that's it
video got over a million views overnight
i believe it went viral
brother gabriel made a response video to
that saying that
you know like essentially what he was
saying now like where do you draw the
line right
we live in a society today where you got
a lot of men
who are true muslim men with integrity
and value
who say i don't want to wear pink right
i don't want to wear pink because
it only goes one way don't leads one
direction but you also got society
telling you it's okay to wear pink
because it doesn't make you gay yeah i
agree
bro wearing pink does not make you gay
but
it only leads one direction you get what
i mean like there's nothing wrong
inherently with wearing pink but it's
like
why would you not rather wear any of
these other colors and why are you now
advocating wearing pink why are you
having two three million followers
making videos wearing pink that's
that's the kind of vibe i'm getting from
gabriel now all he did was make a video
response to that and you got alidawah
you got all these channels canceling him
calling him out saying
and there's women that are in our
comments too because you know they
they somehow think that we're evil now
and they they're writing stuff like oh
uh
what is what is this why does knitting
make you feminine you know i want a man
that can do basic life skills like cook
clean knit here's the thing though
if if men have been you know reduced
today so
to be able to cook clean and and knit as
as things that we got to do
subhanallah man the times we're living
but before we get into that
um i just wanted to give a quick you
know shout out to musti men you know
everything you do 100 but you know what
we're gonna you know kind of dissect and
go over in this video is essentially the
damage that could be done
right and brother gabriel is actually in
the front lines dealing with all these
men and women these boys and girls that
are going through all these identity
issues
these identity crisis and what you said
man it's
to someone that isn't caught up to speed
with uh new laws
and you know reformations they might
think that you're
not 100 on what you're saying about the
law about the puberty blockers but
you're right man
i saw it yesterday it was uh if you want
to not go through puberty
this is for kids because you are
confused by this whole movement
you want to you know explore your
sexuality decide what you want to be
well we all know you could take puberty
blockers but if you as a parent today
you want to stop your kid from taking
those drugs
which cause cancer a lot of different
other issues suicide rates we're not
even going to get into that if you want
to stop your kid from doing that
the government can take your child away
this is 2021 this is ladies and
gentlemen
the united states of america not you
know some weird oppressive country
but my brother should i say it is but
you know why this is
why did it come to this level to this
point bro
it's because people chickened out
to speak against it when they could they
there did not stop it so what happens is
when you
step back okay all of you are into
martial arts
when you step back you know very well
you should never step back in a line
you always circle so you can always keep
going face to face okay
you step back your opponent is going to
step forward till they catch you in a
corner then they're going to pound you
okay we're in the corner we're getting
pounded because we step
back because people are scared why
oh i'll lose my followers i lose my
paycheck
i lose my job i lose my family i lose i
lose i'll lose i
lose okay and that's what i said in my
video
imagine if imam ahmed would have had
that mentality
okay we would not have the correct
takita and we would all believe that the
quran is created
that was one of my points okay we have
reached this level into these weird laws
okay and you by the way you can fight
this intellectually without getting in
trouble
just gotta use your brain have some
heart okay
you're gonna step back guess what these
people are stepping for and when you
look at these people
they look weak man
you know and we got the muscles and the
strength and this and that
and we're stepping back because not
about it's about heart
and they are getting more and more brave
because we're getting weaker and weaker
so we're stepping back and back they're
stepping forth
1000 let me get on over craig's uh
input on so far what you guys been
hearing
agree disagree um oh man you're a lot to
unpack here
[Music]
so i guess i get to be the panel bad guy
i'm gonna go ahead and be back i'm i'm
not a fan of multi-mink at all
i haven't been for quite some time um
on different issues that you know
obviously could be debated but we don't
want to debate here
but in some matters of like you know his
statements on conversion from one
religion to the other and
you know some of his statements on
gender stuff uh has been quite
questionable at best uh
so i don't want to go into details of
that since we're not
since we're not here to discuss that so
but that said i haven't been a fan for a
while and so a lot of his actions
already are going to be dubious to me
from from that perspective alone but
yeah knitting and his statements on
i think i actually did see this part if
i uh where he said i i missed the
quacking and the duck part but like my
wife says move here i'm gonna move there
just to make her happy and this that the
other
and what we since you know hum did our
brother gabriel covered it you know
very well uh i'm going to come from it
from the relationship aspect and it's
just from a simple relationship aspect
this is what we call beta
betazation by a thousand cuts so she
gets you to do this then she gets you to
do that then you do this then you do
this do this this and then eventually
what's happening is
your frame becomes her frame and it's
not supposed to be like that
the masculine flame has and will always
be the dominant one and the one that
women want the most
and so when you allow that transition to
take place where you'll do
anything to make her happy and it's not
bad to make your wife happy this is not
what i'm saying
but you do it from a masculine frame you
don't do it from a feminine one
and when you start doing these things
i'm gonna move over here and i'm gonna
do this and i'm gonna do that because
she says this
this is what women do women have pro
cooperative attributes this is
femininity they cooperate with masculine
frame
and then when you start just cooperating
just to cooperate well it puts you in a
feminine frame
and then what does she do she
automatically has no choice but to take
a masculine frame you become
unattractive to her
it wrecks your marriage it puts you in a
bad position as a man
so make your wife happy but do it from
the masculine frame
and she likes that when you are a leader
it's not something that she likes and
enjoys you know
her husband's acting like i say this all
the time you can't love your wife the
way she loves you
just imagine if your wife tried to act
all masculine and manually
and love you the way you love her you'd
be like ew
i married a woman i didn't want to marry
some dude you know
acting chick you know walking around the
house all right
baby slap you on the rear you're like
what the hey
is that something you want to experience
as a husband so
what do you think is going to happen to
her if you start acting in a feminine
frame in a feminine way
it's bad advice you know and if you're
going to do that and it works for you
because there are exceptions to every
relationship and every woman and every
person
then fine do that within the context and
the scope of your relationship but
understand
and have enough social acumen and a
relationship acumen because he is in a
position where he's affecting millions
upon millions of people
have enough acumen and understanding to
know that that is exclusive to your
relationship
and it's not the general uh female
consensus when it comes down to what
they find attractive which is
masculinity
i don't care what anyone says women like
masculine men
they will say you know and and actually
before we even get into that let me just
say let me agree again with our brother
uh gabriel mark this is an ideology
issue
and what i think the point that we
actually missed was the hadith of the
messenger of allah peace be upon him
where he said that
my ummah will follow the non-believers
hand by hand spam by handspan to the
point that if one of them entered into a
lizard hole
you would have those from amongst who
would do it and now we have
we we see this happening in what seems
like a very
innocent and innocuous way oh well let's
make the women happy like this isn't
like this like this
but that turns into a whole different
world
when it comes down to just like being
agreeable
and we really from a masculine
perspective
agreeableness it's not something that's
there i'm not saying we're conflictive
combative you know
toxic masculinity and all that garbage
they say
but really agreeableness again is a
feminine attribute
and then we have these situations like
he's speaking about where it's like
gender blockers this that the other and
this entire ideology of like just
men becoming softer becomes okay
and you open literally a door that
cannot be closed
and if it is closed then it's closed
through something horrid and horrible
like the collapse of a society
that forces men to be masculine again
but then we don't want to see that do we
because if we see the collapse of
society what's going to happen it's
going to be a terrible scene
and so really we're at that point where
it's like how do we come back from this
and we as muslims we're the forerunners
of masculinity
it's in our sunnah archery sword
fighting horseback riding
you know all of these things that men
are supposed to be doing
well knitting again like the butter said
where's this fit in the scope of that
you know i put up my videos on my
youtube channel you can see me and my
son
or excuse me on my instagram channel my
son and i i have a boxing bag back there
and we fight we slug it out we train on
the bags and you know
and i understand it's not permissible
but you know what in the real world
people are going to punch my son in the
face we swing for the face
do we hit no not often but we swing but
what do we do
we teach just so people know we're not
there they're busting each other in face
we practice
moving the block we're not trying to
knock teeth out i'm not saying that
makes it okay but what i'm saying is
we deal with the reality of the world of
how we're going to face it as men
and it's just a real problem i've been
trying to get my daughter married
since she was 17. she asked me about her
husband since she was 17. she's 21.
i can find men that can make money all
day but i can't find men
that that can make money and aren't like
general slobs physically
you know and that when i say when i pass
away this guy is going to have
in terms of passing the torch of
guardianship over to him
he could protect my family which is my
daughter
because just because she gets married
and i pass over the leadership to him
that doesn't mean she stops being my
daughter
i still want to see her safe and i'm
going to give her to you yeah
mr 800 bmi
this guy who's producing more estrogen
than her no
this is not what we need to be showing
men because we see this is a real
problem with western muslims we have
adopted the lifestyle of the west
both from ideology and diet and so we
find out that the men
are actually becoming obese like the
societies they live in
and if all of this stuff affects your
masculinity we know for a fact that men
who have high bmi in terms of fat
they produce lower testosterone to the
point that your estrogen can overtake
your testosterone you don't think this
has effect on you
of course it's going to seem appealing
to a guy learning how to knit
if he if you know if his bmi is too high
you know he's going to look at the
unique video oh yeah that looks i'm sure
my girl like that yeah because you're
thinking like a girl because your
estrogen's too high
masculinity i've been lamenting the
condition of masculinity amongst the
woman for quite some time
since i started looking for my daughter
and that's when it really
hit me that like something's wrong from
17 to 21 she's 21 now
it's not that long actually but it just
kind of hit me really starkly when i
started looking around
and you know what the the top brothers
that i found
that were most appropriate for my
daughter were
actually in her age group at the time so
that makes them you know not responsible
enough but they were in my jujitsu club
you know we were doing brazilian jiu
jitsu and i was like wow this kids got
it together
these kids have it together they were
learning the book in the sunnah they
were in combat sports you know what i
mean and they had an
intact masculinity from being in combat
sports now of course our brother covered
more than this but
uh i completely agree with him and i i
told him too
uh we're in a group together and i told
her brother buttercloth feet jason
lockhart
i don't think you need to do that
response video bro i think i think you
said enough i think what you said was
correct
you know and just stay at your ground
you know what i'm saying because people
are going to come at you
and i warned the brothers here you know
our brothers uh
the the three muslims i think i advise
you brothers that you know when you
start getting into this business of like
social media and whatnot
you know and speaking people are going
to come at you just because you say
stuff
that's not really popular but it's true
and the truth is never anything that
people want to take if it was
then the prophets and the messengers
would have never been opposed in their
lifetimes
but we know that when you speak the
truth that puts you on the on the path
of the nbr
and that means you're hated and that
doesn't have to just apply to the book
of the sunnah
necessarily you can just talk about
masculinity and it's 100 correct
and people will hate you for it and this
is what and i'm not saying people hate
our brother gabriel but
he's facing opposition for for the truth
why
why does it make sense it doesn't make
sense get out there
show our brothers and our sisters what
masculinity truly looks like
and maybe we're seeing a situation
where the men don't know and that's not
an insult that's not an attack but maybe
they don't know
so instead of like you know like hey you
know what let me show you some drill
combinations in terms of striking and
kicking and whatnot
i'm going to show you knitting because
that's all he knows and i'm not
attacking a brother
but i'm just saying maybe he doesn't
know that's my excuse for him
but that that doesn't make it okay that
doesn't make it like okay not saying
it's not okay to learn knitting
[Laughter]
for a century where we where we are
surrounded
by people who despise us just for being
us people who are attack our women on
the street
what are you going to do with knitting
your sister's getting attacked on the
street for wearing the cap my wife she
had to go shopping the other day
some dudes started yelling her on the
street we don't respect that out here
i was at work unfortunately so she was
out by herself once but i'm just saying
if i'm a random brother walking down the
street and some dude starts yelling at
my sister down there
i'm gonna whip on my little needles and
like
furiously at him what am i gonna do or
can i run up on this guy
you know what you need to stand down if
you don't i'm going to teach you a
lesson or two here about respecting
people
my sister's in specific you can't run up
all my people like that
we're in the scope of the picture of the
world we live in today does that fit
it doesn't and it's it's a problem man
it's a real problem
and i'm not saying that's the only focus
right there fighting or whatever else
but it's just the general mentality of
this entire
well we gotta bend the knee to women no
we love our women
we love them aloha but it's no problem
to say you love it
there's nothing non-masculine about
loving your woman but that doesn't mean
we we gotta bend the knee and you know
be just jelly in their palms and and put
them on pedestals because
when you put someone on a pedestal what
happens they have no choice but to look
down on you
it's a terrible place to be in when the
person you love and you look down on
them you're just like this pathetic
person
how did i end up here and make there no
doubt and let there be no question i am
in the relationship business this is
what a lot of muslim men end up in a
position where the woman's looking at
this guy and she's like disgusted by him
because she's thinking if if a robber
breaks in the house i'm the one that's
got to go downstairs and check it out
he's screaming crying and climbing out
the window
you know it's a mess
it's bad man brothers are lacking
leadership skills well let me teach you
how to knit baby you know
i had to make decisions and choices that
that that encourage
me to you know be able to put my trust
in you because what would women's cr
crave more than anything else a lot of
guys will say money no it's security
money is the path to security in their
mind they crave security
and that security is emotionally
physically financially
it's in all things and if she has no
security in you no faith in you she
feels no safety with you
what what kind of relationship you're
going to have this is why we see so many
people's relationships falling apart
this is why we see sisters creeping
around the backs of their fathers
you know uh and trying to find a wally i
if i was in here knitting i wouldn't be
surprised and i wouldn't be mad if my
daughter
went and tried to find a husband on her
own and she didn't come to me and say
can you find me
a husband if i was standing here needing
i couldn't blame her and she'd be like
well yeah when i was looking for a man
you was in the corner there knitting i
came over and i was just like
hold up this guy gonna find me a husband
how are you gonna find me a husband you
over here knitting
do you send to me and i'm again i'm not
insulting the brother have some skills
have some hobbies but place it
accordingly
you know hey you know what i got a hobby
and my hobby is knitting
but you know to make it
that you you said it best man and it's
not it's not just
brothers that are misled and you know
kind of cheap to society like you're
saying it's sisters too because
you know brothers don't know maybe what
masculinity is but sisters don't know
either
and where are we going to learn from our
sisters because sisters are going to be
vulnerable to feminist property and in
ideology
telling them that oh a real man does
this real man does that when it's like
come on like where you gonna draw the
line right and it's
a perfect example to show how society
works and shaitan works
uh to uh of americans point is this
whole thing with the lockdown right they
started with
one two weeks to flatten the curve then
it's like another two weeks and now you
were
a year plus in right like where do you
draw the line and now
it's not so out there it's not so left
field that
we're just we what couple months have
gone by we haven't left the house
but if somebody told us this 2019 we'd
be like you're crazy
this though we would never allow this we
would protest we would do this
at times we living right because [ __ ]
down works in stages oh no you got you
got something to say
so far but i got a lot to say man
i got a lot to say that that was
hilarious by the way
yeah it's talking about like
my guy if you're gonna learn how to knit
at least learn how to fight too so if
you're on the street and then some guy
is yelling at uh
some muslimah bro you could be knitting
all you want be like hold up hold my
pins
and then you go over there and you do
something about it you know but like if
all you know
all you know is how to knit what are you
gonna do with that
you feel me and again brother i don't
want to talk bad
about this guy or any guy in general
because like i mean
dude if he wants to knit by all means
bro enjoy knitting
but it's like man you do realize like
there are
millions of people watching and like out
of those millions like a lot of them are
dudes
and guys like it doesn't matter if
you're 20 years old 30 40 50
like we we still monkey sea monkey do
and we we observe and we take these
things in
like as a kid we used to look at our
fathers or
or our friends or the other men or other
people in our surroundings and we would
learn
through observation so imagine now
imagine you have all these people
looking at mufti men and he's talking
about these things and again bro
there might not be anything inherently
wrong with what he's saying
in his situation but for other people
that's where it becomes an issue where
it's like all right you have all these
people watching you
it's like you need to set the example
you can't tell them hey you should you
should start
knitting knitting would be great for you
it's like okay
maybe that might be a little side thing
that might help but it's like
you should tell them hey you should
learn how to make more money
you should learn how to take care of
yourself you should learn how to defend
yourself
you should learn how to uh
build things out of nothing like go
outside in nature
and be able to like survive for a week
with nothing you know like you knowing
that
what could you do with that and bro can
i just jump in here real quick
go ahead and take too much time but i
just want to say you made a very good
point also
that he's in front of millions of people
and you have to understand he's not only
in front of muslims he's in front of
non-muslims
since when do we want as muslims to
display an image of weakness or softness
would you think
what do you think a guy is going to look
at muslims dudes knitting and stuff
dude really when we look at the
situation and may allah grant paradise
to our brothers and sisters
who who died in that attack where the
guy came into the massachusetts shooting
up people where was this in somewhere in
new zealand or something or
it was amazing new zealand christ church
do you really think he had an image in
his mind that these were strong
people do you know what i mean under no
circumstances somehow in his mind he
thought i could go in here easily and
take these people out
well if we and people this is a big
problem that muslims are afraid to
appear
strong because we might be seen as
terrorists
really okay fine and stay away from me
you know what i mean you'll find out i'm
not one
but i don't care if you have in your
mind that i am dangerous that's okay
tell you one thing
there's there's a couple messages in the
bronx where the gangsters
won't walk by the street bro there you
go the gangsters are not gonna walk by
those brothers by those communities the
gangsters bro
they're not going to walk by there by
alhamdulillah
okay so beautiful those brothers clean
up those neighborhoods they cleaned up
some of those neighborhoods
yeah with uh yeah he made a good point
it's a beautiful point you know
it's not only millions of people from
amongst the muslims looking at you it's
also the non-muslims
and i'd like to portray an image of
strength because when i'm walking down
the street and i'll give you just a
quick story and i'll let the brother go
back i apologize i don't want to take
too much time from him
but i was i was in um neuschwanstein
down in bavaria with my wife we're
walking up to that you know
famous castle and this guy he's i can't
i couldn't really hear what he said but
he started saying something to my wife
because my wife wears in the cobb all
the time
and i don't have sas i don't have skinny
arm syndrome you know
so i just said hey shut up and turn
around
i said keep walking got it on video to
this day i could post it online the dude
just
closed his mouth turned around and kept
on walking head down
his wife looking at him like it's like
yeah you got a big mouth when it talks
to a woman but when it comes to me
you know yeah mr nonstick arm syndrome
i'm not going to need it you seriously
i'll come over there and throw you over
this wall homie would you
you know what are you doing so what are
we
we're in a wholly different world as
muslims
and i don't see the benefit to that
right now
who are calling for women to stand up to
be powerful to be strong
to take to be independent financially
to go to the gym to take martial arts
what not right and now you got you know
they're slapping around their husbands
you know what i mean and people are
saying you're joking man there's no such
thing no there is
i have cases okay of women abusing men
physically
all right and don't you know people
shouldn't be just dismissing things so
who are you
you know some guys are like you need
counseling there's something you're sick
you're a narcissist you're this
it's easy to throw labels when you're
sitting on your couch behind the screen
you're not working on the ground you
don't got you know thousands of cases
you're not counseling you don't have
parents coming to your office
you know their kids wanting to knit or
sue or play ballet or
you know wear pink clothes or whatever
the heck you know what i mean
you don't have that you don't have kids
who are addicted to gay porn
you don't have muslim sisters who are
watching lesbian porn you know
you know you don't have these things you
don't have people are committing zina
maybe there comes here and there maybe
some people
i'm not saying zero i'm sure all of the
guys will have
some people messaging them and they do
some form of counseling
but at the same time you know to what
extent
and why not why don't you talk about it
then if you do if you are exposed to
this you're dealing with these things
okay
have you looked at the curriculums of
our schools of our countries and where
it's going now have you looked at these
curriculum documents
and see how they're uh changing things
what they're infiltrating inside
teaching kids as young as four or five
that it doesn't matter you're you're not
a boy or a girl you're just
nothing you know you can decide later
you can be whatever you want to be
pocahontas if you want could be a
chicken a duck
or whatever you know it doesn't matter
whatever suits you
i was just uh you know uh commenting on
uh
jose walter uh i cannot remember his
name but he was talking about how his
grandma was
making girls clothes she was she was
knitting and sewing sewing she was
sewing girl's clothes and how she
got him into it and how she made him
wear dresses and she thought it's cute
and many parents
make this mistake sometimes that you
know they have a boy and they're like i
wanted a girl and they tried to wear
them you know to to put little clothes
on them make them all cute and whatnot
you don't understand you don't
understand that walter says that this
was
abuse because a parent should tell their
child at this age
this is wrong even if they're curious
even if they have a curiosity curiosity
can be
sparked from anywhere even if you're
curious a parent is responsible
to understand especially a muslim parent
who knows who believes in wales
and the man is not like the woman okay
to tell them hey this is not
behavior so there was this basically
post by mufti bank okay about knitting
and it's not the only one okay people
think i picked on knitting oh brother
gabriel thinks knitting is haram where
did i say knitting is
nowhere nowhere.
who came in and you know gave me advice
and then you know
pointed out something so i said brothers
i did not say it's haram
all i'm saying is that in today's
concept is something feminine
and if people don't see that then masha
allah okay go ahead
start a knitting club it's okay no
problem all right but and people don't
see it they think it's just an attack
they see
i'm looking only at this they don't
understand
what's what's happening you know what's
what's happening
with the with the cases and the issues
and the problems and the you know the
they don't understand no it's just he's
just picking on someone it's not picking
on anyone it is a war that's being waged
i was checking curriculum documents 10
years ago
in the muslim countries and i was going
and arguing with them guys we're not
taking the right direction
okay and i'll be warned and i was being
you know
pushed back and forth and whatnot and
the people don't understand
this is systematic it's attacking us and
my only point was
to mufti meg brother this is feminine
you should you have a huge following you
should be talking about things that are
more masculine you being a man
you want to teach knitting get your you
know your wife to maybe teach your girls
and you can show her from the back
whatever she's wearing
because he posted a sister with niqab
right now with some book you know
recommending some books so it's okay
i think he's okay with that and no
issues we or we're cool
you know and then so it's that was just
all that i was saying there's other
posts as well that i had issues with
because i've been
looking at these things and people are
sending me things
always what do you think about this what
do you think about that and i just had
to say something i said something before
about the you know chicken or
walking like a duck and so on because i
felt that you know these kind of jokes
sometimes
people think they're um they're not so
you know they're just innocent but
actually then when the husbands come to
you and they're like bro
my wife is like you know saying i should
be like this
why why am i not like this why why don't
i give her the 4-1-1 when she calls me
to tell her to give the full report
just like that and i should move if she
says move and i should quack if she says
quack
why why well because he doesn't
i want a husband like him why can't i be
a husband like him okay
so these jokes and the men are sitting
there putting their heads up down and
laughing
they're funny and whatnot but there's a
lot of reality behind that you know like
you know the mother-in-law is the in-law
and the father-in-law's in-law
but the woman is the law right
everyone's laughing and haha
okay all right it's funny yeah but then
when the cases come in
and there's divorce issues and there's
abuse issues
and you know the woman tells the man you
know sit down and shut up and stuff like
that he loses his temper and this and
that and she slaps him and he punches
her back and this and that
teeth come missing and whatnot people
don't understand that the thing is
i'm not blaming him for this or anything
anyone else but people
you know they have to take their own uh
responsibility but
there's directly and indirectly there's
a problem so i just
said that i think he could make with all
his followers
focus a bit more on these issues like i
just questioned why doesn't he talk
about akhida which is a huge important
thing muslims don't know is allah
how can you solve the problems of the
world if you do not
know who is allah subhanahu ta'ala
people say there's difference and this
and
all right but everyone's responsible to
find the truth
everyone's responsible to look at the
info no we want to be inclusive
yeah but inclusiveness is is a
non-muslim term
it's a term coined by the ones who are
attacking this who are saying that there
shouldn't be
no difference between truth and
falsehood that's what inclusiveness
means it's not about you know
issues of color why are people putting
things under
the umbrella of color on the umbrella of
gender or the umbrella
of you know different uh social classes
no no no
this is bigger than that no no this is
this is about truth and falsehood so why
questions it's a question you know i
mean it is a question
why not why not talk about feminism it's
not an issue oh it is a huge issue
okay i understand you don't want to talk
about politics and stuff like that is
quite i think that i've said many times
and people are asking why are you not
talking about this and that
it's because there's so many people have
no clue what they're talking about get
involved in this
okay and you know cause more trouble and
that's it's a difference but here we're
talking about lives you know you're
talking about war you talk about killing
when they get into you know politics and
what's happening is here what's
happening there and then
okay this needs special qualification
and not only from
from just you know the theme perspective
okay
so but we talk about feminism when you
talk about intellectual
wars you know wars of ideology
well i think that's what we're doing
here you know what i mean i think we're
going to talk about feminism lgbt
are we scared and that's the issue
people as ali dao said you know he could
get in trouble if he does horsing and
shooting really
come on man i mean okay then it means
we're having a problem are we scared are
what are we doing something wrong like
we're not
calling people to attack someone i've
made i have i i'm
i annoy myself with the amount of
disclaimers i make
i understand we're in tough times but so
are the muslims when the mongols attack
so was the process of selling when the
quraysh were you know killing
uh you know uh eliasso you know and he
has to walk by and see it
uh they made migration to abyssinia um
you you name it bro when were we
not in hard times you know so was luth
when he was the pretty much him and his
family were the only one was he living
in a muslim country
no he was within their environment and
still he said the truth
now i'm not saying give up wisdom i'm
not saying be just a loud mouth just a
loose trigger no what i'm saying is why
are we not you are responsible
man like people are responsible to talk
about these important things
because people are confused those
millions of people are following you
they're confused they don't under they
don't care about
islam has become a religion is that's
what we made it into
and as the prophet saws said like you
think the numbers matter you think that
if your numbers increase or followers
the prophet says
it's like the form on the top of the sea
it does not matter
you know says
is that with islam whoever seeks isa
with other than islam allah
will this this honor them so
i'm not picking personally
directly i'm talking about i'm asking
some questions what was the objective
and so on and so forth
people got all mad and whatnot because
of what they didn't they didn't
respond to my argument other than the
knitting are you saying knitting is
haram i'm not saying
i is i'm saying it's feminine oh but
imam ahmed
okay one brother mashallah respect me
send me this it wasn't knitting it was
it was weaving
and that is on a machine usually and
it's for purpose of
selling and buying and you know if you
have a trade or some no problem
even if you have to support your family
that's the only thing i'm not talking
about that i was talking about how it's
looking and how what's representing it
that's it and my question was why don't
we talk about more masculine things
why don't we talk about more real things
when you can make a huge impact
because yes the people are very very
confused and they're getting more and
more confused and you see
more and more of that is online yeah
this is
haram but we can work with them this is
haram but
it's okay for us to join hands with them
it's this
haram but i will fight for their rights
like come on man to what point where are
you going to stop
you think you might know the limit but
the people are asking you
who are looking at you they might not
know the limit okay
and not everyone's going to go back to
you and ask you hey man what do you
think at this point is it allowed now or
can i do this or that
in the back of the mind she's going to
say well i remember that they said you
know we can
it's okay and of course if anyone says
anything
you'll be labeled bigot intolerant this
and that
anyway um i've said what i had to say uh
he just called me right now actually
okay
i couldn't answer because we're getting
ready for this um i would talk to him
and you know i'm not sure how
you know hamdulillah from the brothers i
guess he got my number it's okay i
i i appreciate the fact that he's trying
to call me we'll talk like men to men
and that's it no problem called you
right
yeah yeah just now yeah okay okay i
appreciate that
but uh you know i stand my ground that's
it i mean i'm not gonna
you know yeah that reminds me a lot of
uh what faraz zahabi
said you guys know faraz
oh he's a dope guy dope guy
but anyways he said that uh people don't
know the reality
of violence like people watch
an action movie and they think they know
what violence is
you know they watch like these fighting
movies or like these fights on tv
and they think they know what it is but
it's like they've never actually
experienced it firsthand
and it's like bro i just want to touch
on something here right
gabriel said this one thing where he's
like
you know a lot of people want to chime
in and they want to say oh well
you shouldn't be talking about this you
you shouldn't be saying
uh things in that manner and he said oh
what's easy to say these things
when you're not on the front lines you
know you're sitting back on your couch
just chilling
you have all the comfort in the world
and like bro i made a video
talking about the whole situation with
the the wii u's
if i said that correctly if i said
incorrectly that's on me
but um this one dude chimed in he was
saying like oh i think
we should all just be loving
and spread positivity and that we
we shouldn't these people that are doing
this we should just um
[Music]
i can't even recall everything but it
was just it was
in my in my opinion it was stupid and i
told him since
i was like look dude like i got love for
you but you sound like you don't know
what
the reality of violence is like i'm not
saying i'm over here
being oppressed like them but i was
depressed for a big part of my life so
like i know
what it's like i know what it's like to
have that violence
every single day and it's like dude what
you're saying right now
there's a disconnect there's a
disconnect
and man like finishing this whole thing
about uh the masculine traits masculine
hobbies
are like it's all right to be
you know um how do i say this i'm not
gonna say peaceful but
it's all right to be uh let's say
approachable
right like we'll say approachable
because that's that's more fitting for a
man
because like you guys got to understand
like as a man
we are savages and we are animals
and like you push any man to the corner
and the animal will come out so it's
like if you have that animal inside of
you
then you understand that you're just
playing this game of like okay
um how how can i hold this animal back
to the best degree
but not suppress myself to where it's
like okay well now i'm being a cuck
you know what i'm saying was like dude
every guy has this innate feeling of
like
okay if someone is uh if someone is
trying me if someone is uh putting me
down like i'm gonna fight back
i'm gonna fight back every man has that
and they feel so if you have that innate
feeling
and like someone's putting you down and
you decide no i'm gonna push this down
i'm not gonna fight back i'm just gonna
take what they're giving me
you're doing a lot of harm you know
you're doing a lot of harm and
i think if if someone is in that
situation
and guys i'm all over the place here but
i feel like there's a method to my
madness right now
and if i want to comment on you yeah
yeah if someone's in the situation
like brother musti mink where they have
millions
of dudes watching muslims and
non-muslims like
you need to set the example you need to
set the example
and like bro if him and i would ever
talk i would say the same thing i mean
obviously who have he'll have his side
of the story and that's
100 fine but i'm saying like i speak
from my own personal experiences like
dude i set the example every single day
for
every single person i meet every single
person that you know comes into contact
with my videos and
for myself most specifically because
like when no one's watching
um obviously the creator is watching but
you yourself are watching yourselves
and if you're acting weak then you're
basically showing yourself that you're
weak
so i mean i i could keep going here but
i'm gonna let one of y'all take it here
can i jump in there real quick again
yeah
and again i always speak from a position
relationships because that's the thing i
do
um and from a relationship aspect you
made also another point
and there's a there's a mechanism in
women called cabristophilia
and hebristophilia is a mechanism within
women that cause them to find a degree
of attraction
significant to men who are capable of
violence
this is obviously relates to security
and feeling protected
you know it's nice that you can knit it
really is
there's no problem at its core with
knitting
the issue is that whole ah it's cute and
whatever else
it has to come from a position of
strength
and we're not seeing that as a common
trait amongst the ummah today
anything you do that's cute and
lovey-dovey
has to be done from a position of
strength so when you know even when they
come and they say oh well there's a
deity to the messenger of allah being
like this and being like that and being
gentleman's kind
this was yeah we're talking about the
mystery of allah peace be upon him and
his sahaba yes they were gentle and kind
to their wives but you look at the
context of the time
these were men that would also go out
and run a man through with a spear and
cut his head off
then come home with a bloody sword and
shield and sit down and eat with his
wife
that's amazing that this man is gentle
and kind
because he as a regular behavior had to
go out and slaughter
and butcher men and if you ever
slaughtered an animal if you've gone
down and slaughtered a sheep
you know the first time you do it it's
not that simple you get that loose hand
feeling and it's just like
i'm gonna cut this animal's throat now
imagine going on that note of people
these were men of strength and so
kindness and gentleness
was amazing because all they had was a
harsh environment
we get up iphones android
food electricity power we're soft
we can get in our car and drive like a
half a kilometer down the road to go
shopping these guys masha allah may
allah grant them all paradise
they walked or rode days
to do basic simple trading these are not
men who are like us
do not make the comparison of the hadith
of how these men responded and i'm not
saying don't be kind and gentle and
ignore the hadith
we're in different times and so no but
do these things from a position
of strength knit from a position of
strength
may allah guide him what is right and
correct both an ideology
and an action but i do not see mufti
ming coming from a position of strength
i ain't seeing him out with some gloves
on slugging on that bag like showing
some slalom combinations like yo okay
mashallah
he's teaching her brother some stuff
today has posted a video of him
skydiving
after this discussion you know okay good
that's okay
actually and alidawah mentioned that
ali mentioned that he slaughtered like
in one day 50 cows or something like
that i don't know mashallah i said okay
no problem man that's good
but we don't see that oh because it's by
it's uh you know it's many people put
post things of slaughtering and whatnot
you don't have to show the blood gushing
or anything like that
my issue was with i'm not saying he's
not a man
or anything like that i'm just saying
that portray
in your post that you are aware
of what's going on and which side you're
standing on
you know what i mean what you're doing
because a lot of boys and
males are watching you and they're
taking you as an example
so if you're showing them knitting
they're going to do knitting if you
showed them
horse riding or archery or skydiving
mashallah alhamdulillah i mean they're
going to try to
to do that they're gonna get that vibe
you know what i mean so
why not post ali dawa said again that
it would get him in trouble i don't know
i mean this whole getting in trouble
thing
i think it's a it's kind of um coming
from a fear perspective as
alba american says right from a weak
perspective right
you're you're showing weakness you know
we're not terrorists we're not
uh calling for anyone to do anything
we're proper
here talking about real stuff man uh and
one of the things that i wanted
subhanallah you know the prophet saws
you know he tells us the hadith a lot of
people don't like this hadith and try to
you know go back and forth you know
interpret and misinterpret it's
always associated to jihadis and this
and that you know
that islam
you know islam started something strange
and it will return to something strange
so give glad tiding to the strangers
well bottom line is
talk about a lot uh recently you've had
people
totally talking awful offline about it
but anyway
um when we look at the context of the
messenger sallallahu alaihi
why was he considered strange or a
stranger because
he was not going with the flow in his
society okay
it was not about the numbers that was
the whole point the culture
and the flow in the society was
something totally different and he came
up with something against it
be it on the level of akida and tawhid
okay that was the main thing and then at
the social level with bearing the
daughters with inheritance with you name
it
the prophet saws was basically going the
other way and they've tried to do
everything
okay um
you know that narrates the the story
about how the quraish approached abu
talib he said look we'll make him the
king we'll make him whatever
you know just give it up and he says no
put the sun in my right hand the moon in
my left i'm not going to give it up
you know so but today
we see a lot of the guys and a lot of
the people who are doing that have a lot
of followers
is subhan allah everyone is agreeing
with them they're within this realm
of being agreeable everyone's even the
non-muslims are saying you should be
like this subhanallah
don't you want to be like this guy or
you guys are too extreme or too harsh
so essentially they're not saying
anything strange anymore
right you shouldn't tell the christian
that the trinity is wrong no no you're
gonna upset him
you shouldn't tell the christian that
hey if he's not accepting islam there's
a chance a good chance of going to hell
no no no now there's our brothers are
coming up with all kinds of
uh academic papers to show that
you know maybe there's a difference of
opinion and you know i know some people
go to make will go to jannah
um you shouldn't tell lgbqt that's wrong
because you're gonna upset them you
shouldn't you shouldn't you shouldn't
because everyone's going to get upset
everyone we have to be careful with
everyone getting upset
but when these people talk about the
message of allah or
islam or this and that no no brother you
know let's not cause fitna right now
that's not uh
you know no no they're attacking our
masculinity they're they're making you
know feminism is
smashing it no no brother you know be
careful this is gonna cause troubles fit
now we don't need to
so what's going on everyone's going with
the flow you're not a stranger and i'm
not saying
to be some lunatic or something like
that where everyone's like what's wrong
with this guy
i'm saying is that if you're gonna speak
the truth this is the sunnah he said
islam started something strange it will
come back as something strange
the thing is that i have with these
brothers is that they're not saying
something strange from the perspective
of the 21st century global
so-called society that accepts lgbt
that is changing the curriculum that is
teaching your four-year-old that it's
okay to have two dads
and it's okay to have two moms and you
you're not a boy or a girl you can
you know choose later i don't know today
i watched they came up with a new term i
can't even pronounce some of these terms
you know
it's like there's a new term where the
baby's born he's not really a baby it's
like i don't know
god some weird name that they came up
you know so they don't want to they
don't want to
they don't want to divulge the gender of
the child
like and this is like this is the normal
man like so you're going with this
you don't no i don't want to talk about
i don't agree you know i don't agree
with it but i'm not going to talk about
it
but everyone else who's following you
are going back to their daily lives and
they're being exposed to
all this nonsense and by us not talking
about it
and not highlighting it well i'm not
saying you're saying it's halal but
to an extent you're responsible man you
are responsible the
islam is not bashiron okay
you give glad tidings but you warn you
know what did the process him do the
first thing when the
call became public the first thing he
says i
warn you there's an army coming if
there's an army coming would you believe
me they said yes
i warn you of a punishment from allah i
am the messenger of allah
you have the obligation to follow me he
didn't say oh you know
brothers it's okay you know let's love
each other i love you all first you know
for the sake of god if you're a jewish
christian
or muslim whatever atheist it's okay
no i'm sorry that's not how it works man
because
you're saying i love the people i love
everyone love what you love the killer
the murderer the abuser the pedophile
okay it's another big group that's
coming up right now following the lgbqt
and
they've learned they got the blueprint
of how to move up the pedophiles and
slowly it's called
love is love okay love is love meaning
doesn't matter
people are i don't know man people are
in a different world man
where are you living in a tick tick tock
world or what you know it's just
come back to the ground there's a huge
battle
that's being fought if you're not
willing to be a stranger and to stand
around and yes you will lose certain
things
that's how americans said people come to
you you better stand your ground and
that's why knitting's not going to help
you if you want to train you need to
become strong it's not it's about
punching and stuff like that it's mental
resilience it's about having that spirit
to be able to it's not that everyone's
going to get the big muscles and whatnot
but sometimes you see just a little guy
but it's got heart you know what i mean
is going to be able to stand this ground
it's not just about combat it's about
that this war is way beyond the physical
fight
it's intellectual it's but if you don't
have the guts if you don't
have the heart if you're not willing to
sacrifice your family your salary
like all the sahabas like all the mba
that is
it look at their lives man did they say
something like you know maybe the board
masjid board is gonna fire me oh i can't
really you know when i talk when i ask
some of these brothers bro why don't you
guys talk about this
you know what one brother says what he
says i'm a coward he said i'm scared of
my wife
i swear by allah on this video that he
and he's the sheikh masha'allah he said
i'm a coward i'm scared of my wife
others have said no we're gonna we're
gonna uh you know
the board is gonna fire us uh our
paychecks our families we gotta take
care of our families and say
i understand i'm not saying throw them
under a bus man i'm not
saying that but if you're not willing
to stand up and fight well we're going
to end up
not recognizing ourselves anymore man
bro you know that's two things
my bad let me let me come in real quick
that's two things that are like super
important
for a man is number one being able to
stand your ground and speak the truth
no matter the situation right and then
like
number two building being willing to
lose
everything for what you are standing up
for
because it's like my guy a perfect
example me
and fayette and this other dude went to
iceland like
i'm i'm very chilled out very relaxed
but you know what like if you push me
like i'll snap on a dime like i'll
i'll let that animal out real quick we
were at this uh one river where there
was this uh
these uh these big giant glaciers like
floating down the resorts
yeah and like i'm over here grabbing
like other
pieces of ice and rocks and just
throwing them at the other like glaciers
trying to hit them bro just having fun
and um i'm just enjoying myself being
being cool being calm collective
and fire's there the other dude's there
the other dude joins me
and then i hit this one glacier one of
the little pieces of ice breaks off
and then this person in the crowd
basically
calls me an idiot and telling me to grow
up
bro i literally turned around i was like
who are you talking to
like who's an idiot bro they all didn't
know what to say bro
and i have their own video just like uh
abu american has the
the thing where he told that guy to be
quiet on video
um but the last thing that i want to say
to you
is like you have to be willing to lose
everything because it's like it
if you if you can't stand for that then
you don't stand for anything
you're gonna fall for anything it's like
you can't put up an excuse and like ah i
need to
uh take care of my family okay that's
perfectly understandable but
you do understand by you saying oh well
i'm not gonna speak my truth i'm not
gonna stand my ground because i need to
i need to provide for my family you're
trying to play
god here when it's like dude if you
stand up
and you stand your ground even if you
lose your job like
guaranteed allah will provide you
with whatever it is that you need no
doubt man not that i mean it's so it
hurts me to say you know i'm not trying
to show off anything like that you know
you guys are in non-muslim countries a
lot of you and
i'm in a i'm in a muslim country i'm
working
for an islamic school i am a school
principal
okay um i've been working as a principal
for years
i got warning letters from my school
because of my social media activities
specifically now
on this movie bank issue the owner of
the school
recently you know had a huge debate with
me and parents are complaining
and i say why give me why your kids are
becoming gay man
what are you complaining about i'm
trying i'm if you don't care if you
don't give a
nothing about your kids i will i do
i care they're my little brothers and
sisters if you don't care about your own
kids
what a shame man if you don't see bro
there's such a huge push here malaysia
muslim country on the lgbqt uh how many
i see
all again allah is my witness every
day or second day i see lesbian couples
walking on the street
apparent clear hijabi sister bro with
boycott little asian looking like dude
girl
you know and i asked my students about
this it's just a serb they call him
service boy or service
girl you know what i mean hijabi sisters
bro
it's a big thing you know what i mean
there's their kids they don't care about
i get warning letters bro i got when i
did the uh the polygyny series
and the lgbqt thing uh back about uh it
was in 2020
and during the lockdown god like the
board if the board of directors gave me
an official warning letter saying i'm
causing
fitna are you kidding me bro
are you kidding me muslim country
you know in my last day and i was april
first for many different reasons but
whatever
alhamdulillah for everything you know
what i mean uh but
what a joke man what a joke muslims
muslim school muslim country islamic
school that says
we're building future champions islam
look at the mission and vision based on
quran and sunnah
in the mission and bishop based on quran
so which quran bro
which sunnah you know people are going
to be like bro why are you getting angry
bro why you
you know it's your your body language is
your you're too hot
man the mystery of allah would get red
man
he would give the hood by holding a
sword in his in his hand sometimes
which quran which surname are we talking
about what what's this
where is it i mean anyway
i just want to say a good point go ahead
and go mine let's just jump in
you made a good point it's like if
you're dawa especially
for those uh public figures who are
living in normal some countries if your
dawah
doesn't differentiate or cause like some
sort of like
friction with the local society you're
in
there's a problem because you are
teaching people from a stance of
al-qaeda and men
there's no need to be different than the
people in your surroundings
well we know that's not correct as
muslims we are different than the people
in our surroundings they're not muslims
we're muslims
we are different and so why should they
feel comfortable about that difference
do we feel comfortable
i don't really feel comfortable walking
around the non-muslims in a sense i go
to work people are it's legal in germany
to drink beer and alcohol on the job
they're offering tomorrow right now i'm
good man you know what i mean
it's uncomfortable for me out here when
it's christmas time they're like oh come
to the christmas party
i it makes me uncomfortable
there should be something that
differentiates us between them
you know what i mean and that doesn't
have to be comfortable it doesn't have
to be
a confrontational conflict but there is
a difference
and germans say oh well muslims don't
belong in this environment i'm like yeah
you know what you're probably right
because you guys are disbelievers and
you guys are in this country you're
probably right we should probably
shouldn't be here
they think this is going to harm me and
i'm like no it doesn't harm me i agree
with you
why i was just born out in these parts i
just grew up out here so i'm just kind
of here guy
but i do i want to be here no i want to
be amongst the muslims so your
dawah should be something that caused
people to actually stop
listen to you and think if it's just
like oh yeah he just that sounds good
well okay now where's your dowa to him
to him he thinks
your ideology and your and and and your
ideology
them too they see no difference oh well
love peace and hair grease we're all
good
no no we're not no we're not we're not
because this iman this this
separates us this is a barrier between
us and it can never be
it can never be crossed unless one of us
goes the other way it may allah protect
us from going that way
they need to come this way this is our
duty to make them stop
and think and does it have to be
uncomfortable yeah absolutely because if
you convert to islam or you consider it
or you think about islam
it should be thinking yeah this is going
to be an entire change to my entire life
and the way i
live well i don't see that happening
amongst a lot of these callers nowadays
what's the difference between them and
us oh well
you know if a guy wants to be a guy or i
mean a guy wants to be a girl or girl
wants to be a guy or whatever else we're
not even speaking out against it
because we're afraid of being cancelled
there's
a problem and that's a huge problem from
the umma also
how are we as i'm gonna let our people
get canceled
well that means you must somehow
partially agree with the society around
you
that means you're coming from a position
of weakness why would you be scared
why would you be scared if he's speaking
the truth
where's your spine put some spine in it
so this is something that applies to
both the men and women
and then the second point was you know
the focus on fighting isn't really that
everything boils down to a physical
conflict
obviously that's a very unrefined way to
go through life ah you got to disagree
with the guy punch him in the chin no
this is not what we're saying but what
i'm saying is
when you get in the ring constantly i
don't care if jiu jitsu if you don't
want to throw punches you want to do
brazilian jiu jitsu you want to do
boxing muay thai whatever
else i'm the sparring partner for this
state i'm in the state of starland i'm
the sparring partner for all the state
champions
in their weight and age category so i
fight teenagers i fight adults
i fight all weight categories let me
tell you something i love fighting and
i'm good at it
but there is a sense of fear inside of
me when i get in that ring with those
guys
even though i know i can hold my own and
they're not gonna just you know use me
as a punching bag
and what that does is it changes you
internally it changes you here it
changes your chest
it teaches you heart and then when you
know for a fact that you can defend
yourself everything else becomes just
the kind of minor
the fear of your boss the fear of this
the fear of that the fear of not being
able to make it in the world
believe it or not fighting will give you
all of that because you know that you
know what i got
i can get in that ring and i can fight
that dude that's like three weight
classes bigger than me and has had like
80 fights
if i can go in there and stand up to him
what's my job
you're gonna fire me really okay all
right and then what happens you get
fired you find a new job anyway
so it's a matter of removing your fear
and putting you in a new mental frame
that puts you in a mental frame of
strength it puts you in a mental frame
of power and let me tell you something
it it radiates from a person
and your wife notices that and she loves
you for it if you
or you don't knit she's not going to
care she's like look at that dude she's
like wow
let me tell you women love masculinity
i work at a gym right and i've been
working there for a while now
now i see exactly album american's point
he made a live stream um and there was a
question
asked and he was like he said it himself
i i don't fear getting fired i do my i
do my
show and i leave if i gotta put a video
out that says i got three wives i'm not
gonna walk on eggshells thinking that
what if i got fired the next day i
position my life in a way that i'm
comfortable
now again i'm a student i'm not
financially independent like american
but
i don't need my job right i like
training clients at the gym
now i'm not going there and i'm not
gonna uh ask the
the owner of the gym to take my podcast
and my lgbtq episode
and put it and promote it in the in the
front banner i'm not gonna say that
because i know that's gonna get me fired
but i'm not gonna shy away from it if it
comes to a point where somebody tells my
boss oh look look this is what your
employee's doing this is what he stands
up for in 2020 he's talking about lgbt
if it gets to that and they don't take
it the right way call us bro
i'm gonna leave i don't need that job
but until that point you gotta you gotta
play your cards right i'm not gonna
promote my
podcast to everyone there but why would
you to stay at a job as a muslim if
they're going to fire you over a stanza
on lgbqt
or whatever the alphabet crew anyway
imagine that
did you be afraid of being fired from a
job from your stance on that as a muslim
what's the truth of what's the falsehood
what you standing for well
let me be quiet about this falsehood
because i might lose my job really
that's what
this is how this is how fast your line
collapses
really what you gonna do on the front
line in real battle oh my gosh they got
swords too
i thought you said they'd have rubber
ducks
yeah you will collapse there come on
guys
this where you make your stand at this
is the truth you don't like it okay fine
well you know what you believe that
stuff is okay
it's okay for you and your people in
your society it's not okay for me i
don't go around
advocating violence or harm against
anybody but i believe personally this is
not something i like
this is not something that's promoting
my religion and it's not something i
want
for my family if that's a problem you
want to fire me over that then you know
what
this is my battle right here this is my
hill let's go ahead and go to war on it
you want to fire me i'll go somewhere
else where they have ethics values
virtues and morals
that reflect the same that i do or at
least are close enough to it
why would you want to stay at a job like
that well if you don't believe in this
falsehood we're going to fire you
oh are you going to stop at shirk what's
next
you know the the islamic university i
graduated from i was
in my last year you know i don't have to
do some paperwork
and uh somehow i ended up
on some of their policies you know and
it said there we do not
discriminate against sexual orientation
and i was like what the heck is this you
know right
what does that mean you know what i mean
like why do we even have to say this you
know it's become now
that's the thing though what's the
standard the standard is not
truth the standard is not you know
everything is um this center that
center this but it's there's no god
center there's no allah centered
system anymore no one cares about that
you know it's a religion you can have
your religion build a thousand mosques
grow your beer do whatever you want just
don't practice
islam properly pick certain parts okay
fight amongst each other med helps this
that go and go for it no problem
but when it comes to actual full-fledged
islam
no that's that's just not good there you
know we don't want that we don't want
god
that's that's the thing you got to make
your choice are you going to be a
stranger
are you going to be going in the flow
what you're going to do you're going to
face
challenges you're going to face people
opposing your own family i keep that's
what i tell the brothers you know i say
the first people that you get
to fight you so panel sometimes it's
your own family man
and that's what happened with the
prophets you know i mean that's what
happened with the prophets sometimes
their families were opposing them
and i tell the brothers most likely the
first one who's going to tell you cannot
do it stop give up give up this nonsense
will be your wife and that's the reality
man
a lot of times if you haven't picked her
right if you haven't vetted her properly
she's going to be the first one that
you're whipped in by the way anyway
because you know you've been
intimate with her you love her what not
who's gonna be like no honey i don't
think it's a good idea
i don't think you should do this i don't
think you should say this i don't think
you should do that
right and then that's the thing you ask
the brothers bro let's do this
i i gotta check with with my wife first
let me check with her so i'm like check
what you have to take permission or
i just need to run it by her you know
and stuff like that's the thing like
everything is going through through that
channel now
so i don't know man stand your ground
you know what i mean
okay in first year university i wasn't
as
you know woke red told whatever you want
to call it i was kind of you know just
the product of society and
even then bro things that resonate with
our fitnah
with our um with our fit with our inner
guiding compass that is the truth
right even though i was kind of blind i
asked one of my homeboys i was like you
want to get food it was like a friday
night and i remember very specifically
that day
he paused and then he he like he
shrugged a bit i was like i kind of knew
he was a little like
not at ease and i was like what do you
mean like are you down to go get food
he's like
i'm gonna ask my girl and i'll get back
to you
i was like bro what do you mean i'm
gonna obviously i'm gonna leave names
out of this bro but
he was that one couple bro in first year
24 7. you see them together pda all over
each other in public this man was
all over this chick 100 they're not
together anymore they're not together
let me get to the best part i was going
to say that i was the only one that
called it they are not going to get
together
um my wife uh back then would tell me
the same thing not they're going to be
together
i'm rooting for them i was like nah
they're not going to work out
and what do you know they're not
together he she left him
for another guy while she was with him
and
essentially would try to make that guy
my male friend
right because we can have friends too
and
essentially he wasn't he you know no
guy's gonna be cool with that but he
didn't have a ba back on her spine so he
was like
uh okay cool and then it went from we're
just friends to where it went from
two it just happened you know and that's
really
this is reality this is this is not some
we're not saying some fairy tale out
here right so
this is very clear now the whole thing
with lgbt yeah we're not gonna go and
attack every gay guy we see
but we have different views we don't
need to shine away from it now there's a
way to do it there's
but we have to understand that society
and the media is
the enemy it's against us simply put
when you had that gay guy
uh not that gay guy when you had that
guy that muslim guy go into that gay
club
and shoot all those men in that gay club
first thing you see
in the headline is muslim shooter kills
you know opens fire in a gay club
but then nobody tells you oh that guy
himself was gay and he had an affair
with two of those guys or one of those
guys in that club they're not going to
say that but what they are going to say
is
muslim man right exactly so when we see
something like
lgbtq society does this or something
else that's the you know contra positive
we're not gonna we're not gonna
you know promote that we're not gonna
share our views
how does that make sense why are we
always gonna just you know submit to
this whole
ideology that's the thing we're weak
we're weak and because of weakness these
guys are pushing
and pushing i believe we're in a corner
right now i don't know
i mean as a as an umba anyway there are
hamdulilah individuals
that are still standing their ground but
come on in
wherever you're going to go can you give
a hotba let me just this is the
litmus test okay can you give a khutban
any messenger about
lgbqt is it allowed in toronto
is it allowed anywhere else to give a
hotba but
but now they're bringing in what's
called what is it like uh
trainers or whatever you want to call
them social workers to train our
community about
acceptance inclusiveness and all that
yeah
right the messages have to i think it's
by law now that there has to be some
even they have some like i believe there
was a talk in canada i remember the
brothers were saying that
they they will have to at some point
hire a
member of the lgbqt community within the
masjid board
that's that's being put as a law soon
sooner california already passed that
and yeah so i mean
that's the thing you keep giving you
know you're given uh you know you give
an inch you take a you know
a foot and so on and keep going and keep
going so
um you know look uh
i i you know um just recently uh
we we we we commemorated the the
martyrdom of malcolm x
right and there's just so much you can
learn from malcolm x but
one thing that men stood his ground
you know what i mean and because he's to
the ground a lot of people understand
what that did to the you know
african-american movement
and american can jump on it as well you
know i'm coming from that community
masha'allah
but these kind of people stood their
ground
you know what i mean and what they had
to pay for it and they didn't
when they're intimidated when they're
pushed they didn't back
down well in the end
allah will honor you man in the end
allah
even in the whole world dishonors you in
the end allah
will honor you you know what i mean
so i mean yeah this is fact i mean look
at look at malcolm x who remembers
is this let's go with even better
example ahmed who remembers the people
who imprisoned him
you remember imam ahmed right exactly so
it's the same thing with kind of like
with malcolm x it's like yeah we have a
general idea who was against them but
really who are they yeah
exactly stand your ground for the truth
i will give you he'll put noodle on you
on your name on your face people make
dua for you after you're dead you know
as allah subhanahu ta'ala says
you know talking about the shuhada and
subhanallah you know obviously we know
the hadith that there are like green
birds underneath the throne and so on
but in the end they're our life to an
extent
kenny and we don't they they're they're
we're mentioning them
every day talking about them taking
their example
uh you know discussions movies this
that clips about these people
subhanallah you know what i mean how
many times do we say muhammad sallallahu
how many times we talk about um
okay malcolm x and others man throughout
the day throughout the years always
mentioning these guys
hannah laina and other people you don't
even know what's their name you know i
have no clue what happened to them
right so allah honors you when you stand
your grounds
so that's why we gotta we all have to
put it out there for
other men to learn how to fight and i'm
not just talking about like physically
fighting because
but fighting is everything you fight
mentally
and you fight spiritually you fight
emotion you fight physically like
everything in this world is a fight
like in this dunya it's all fighting bro
and standing your ground
is a huge equivalent of fighting and
what uh our american was saying about
the combat sports
you do combat sports and then not
everything else is pretty easy isn't it
it gives you clarity in in a position
where you are in physical fear
and when you put yourself in that
position time after time after time in a
ring of combat with another man
who's trying to harm you there comes a
point where it's like it's
this is just another day and so when you
like i said
that fear disappears because you're used
to operating from a position
of self-defense or aggression in a in a
position
that you feel uncomfortable in it it
rewires you
to be strength and power at all times
yeah man
and then you get handled you get handled
by this uh this spawn
that's right if we look at the the
hadith i mentioned right teach your
children you know
uh swimming horse riding archery right
it's the sunnah right
the process and said teach it's like an
order pretty much okay
and he didn't okay the process uh sold
his clothes
and uh mended his shoes there's hadith
you know but he didn't say teach your
kids that i mean it's a skill you can
learn knitting whatever okay
but he told us teach why because
these activities that help you manage
conflict in your life be it intellectual
spiritual physical conflict you know all
types of conflicts
this will give you the strength you're
exposed to the stimuli
you're exposed to that's what the more
you expose yourself to the stimuli is
the more
they don't have you know the fear
lessens
okay your body is more used to that your
you react faster you know what i mean
and life is about conflict as much as
you want to
negate it deny it because we live again
and uh
interestingly interestingly subhanallah
you keep talking about peace and this
you know yes peace is the absence of
conflict no doubt
but the reality is that the world has
not been at peace you know one of the
poets says that the only time the world
was at peace when they reloaded their
weapons
you know if you look throughout the
world and analyze what's been happening
there's always been conflict that's not
what we want necessarily
but that's just what happened the arabs
and the
the ulama the earlier who wrote the seer
of the prophet
okay that's the way they label it for
the longest time
incidents in the arabs were always
labeled according to wars or maine you
know things that's why amel field the
ear of the elephant is the conflict
okay when the process was born okay um
they're not messing around is that
they're just all let's just fight every
because people might think you know
they're gonna
leave this uh this podcast and they're
gonna think these guys are just wanna
you know
beat the living days out of each other's
homemakers punch everyone
that's what like you know with the tick
tock attention span
you know sometimes i feel that you know
i'm you know people keep saying why keep
giving disclaimers bro because
people don't listen man people don't
listen
to what is the objective and the points
that we're making
so we're not saying that but man combat
is so important to understand to develop
to be able to face the real
life and that's why
people go on shootouts in schools
because they don't know how to handle
differences in combat okay
these days so many shootings in school
in western countries right
people just make a list go get a rifle
go shoot do this now
we used to settle things behind the
bleachers you know
back in the days in the park or whatever
a couple of punches this and that
and that's it you know shake hands now
the guy goes gets a gun gets a knife i
was just talking to a client just before
this
and they're telling me about the
stabbings in the uk
the muslim community and this client was
saying that
you know it was like 4 a.m someone
knocks on the door
they said who is it he said me it's like
the son you know
he's like i was about to open the door
and i look through the crack and i see
three boys with knives
and these are muslim boys like you know
i want to tell their ethnicity or
whatever
you know it's crazy bro i mean
the world is this is a different
different place man
and we need to address this issue why
these boys don't know how to handle
conflict they don't know how to handle
differences they don't know how to
handle
issues they just right though
but but subhanallah
this is you know this is something that
you know the sahaba all knew
how to combat except for there was only
one sahaba
uh who was masha'allah he was a warrior
with his words you know so
uh so uh you know the poet of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam was a
warrior with his words he said i cannot
hold the sword he said i'm coward you
know
other than that i cannot i wish someone
would maybe but i've looked i cannot
recall one sahaba
as abu manikaan said who didn't know how
to come back who didn't
engage including the prophet sallallahu
islam
he actually took the life of one of the
quraish okay with the spear
okay and that is recorded as for others
might be others as well okay
there is not one sahabah who
did not know how to fight again is this
a podcast about
fighting and beating each other no it's
trying to put a point about that muslim
needs strength
we are in a position of weakness we need
strength
we need men to be men we need to return
to the fitra
the fitra
created us on that's why people have
doubts about islam about hadith about oh
maybe i think there's not interpretation
i think it's not opinion
because our fitra is messed up fitra is
the recipient of revelation
if fitra is messed up you will not
understand quran
you're always going to be like i don't
understand this why does it say that
maybe there's a different thing oh i
think this is too harsh
i think sheikh sheikh saw this and this
and that because
you know we're always starting from a
position of doubt
always starting from a position of
questioning you know
that's not how it is man it's not sahaba
say the sahaba had messed up backgrounds
man before islam
if you study their lives with the
backgrounds that they're coming from man
allahu akbar how were they able
to make such a fundamental change in
their life
why do the scholars highlight some of
the
attributes of the quraish of the arabs
of honor
of bravery right they say before islam
they used to have this the honor the
bravery the strength
and all that so when islam came the only
thing that they had to kind of mend was
the issue of truth
what is the truth and what is justice
around that so and then they became and
that's what process
the best amongst you and jahlia is the
best in in islam if they understand
you know and that's why the sahaba
khalid walid
went towards medina you know he was
attacking the pros of sallam he was
fighting
understood the truth made 180 and just
went and
just turned himself the other way and
started doing what he was doing best
that's why he was called the sword of
allah you know what i mean
the best man you know the the women of
benny maxwell will never be
even find a man like khalid you know and
that's what the boys used to say right
this is they're you know where i mean i
get disappointed i i'm
i'm almost like wanna cry and when i
read
the life of the sahaba and the prophet
sallam
and when i see what we have today you
know what i mean
we have soft individuals today
and like bro that's the whole point of
this this whole thing that we're talking
about
is um if we were putting in the show um
okay we'll make it very simple because
like you said people they don't listen
and then when they do listen they
misinterpret
so real simple if you're a man
go learn a combat art once you learn a
combat art
you'll start getting handled in sparring
sessions you'll have to
deal with all the pressure all the fear
all the anxieties that you're gonna feel
and then you'll get to the point where
it's like okay well
now you're getting a little harder and
i'm not talking about you know
sexually i'm talking about like mentally
physically spiritually you're getting
harder bro
where it's like something happens in
your life like
it helps a lot it helps a lot with
intimacy bro that's for sure
yeah yeah for sure for sure but i mean
for this part you know
we'll keep it in regards to life like
this right
so you lose your job like one of you
said okay whatever
like it's nothing to you you just you're
going into this ring
you're learning this combat art you're
facing these fears on a day-to-day basis
you're
basically sharpening your iron every
single day towards like
that doesn't really affect you anymore
you are now hardened
by that experience and it's kind of like
dudes taking cold showers
where it's like a cold shower sucks
anyone will say a cold shower sucks
and then bro you go through that cold
shower you keep doing that and then
mentally
it puts you in a place where you're like
ah okay well if i can handle
a cold shower then i can go out here and
i can
talk to people you know what i mean and
it's like broke
we we as men nowadays are so weak even
the top men
are weak because well like i don't know
about the sahaba i haven't looked into
them that much but
if you look at the top tier athletes in
this world i'm talking about the top of
the top like top combat athletes
uh football players basketball soccer
all these athletes bro
they are a fraction of what the
gladiators and the spartans were now
like i said i don't know the sahaba but
i'm sure they are a fraction of the
sahaba as well
so like if you think if you think that
you are doing
all right as a man if you think you're
doing all right as a man just remind
yourself
that you're just a fraction of what
these people were and even the top
athletes are still just a fraction so
that should let you know hey
maybe i shouldn't be knitting maybe i
should be learning
something useful maybe i should be
developing
myself as a man as a proper man
you know what i mean and if i if i got a
couple million followers if i do know
how to do those things why not promote
that
instead of the knitting no doubt no
doubt
and whatever happens people don't tell
us you you gotta cancel you get canceled
people don't see an issue with
masculinity today and that's one of the
problems we have
that people don't see that there's a
problem with masculinity yeah well
there's nothing wrong with me
you know i have the genitinalia no i've
got the beard i'm a man that makes me
masculine
you know so and it's not really that
simple you know it's not it's an entire
state of being
and there's an equilibrium in there and
and again
we will repeat this knitting is not the
problem
anybody who does combat sports and they
do them intensely knows there's always a
balance where there's an artistic side
that comes out alongside that violence
as a man there's nothing wrong with
enjoying that violence i've never met a
man who's done combat sports and become
proficient at them and hasn't
loved it but at some point he starts to
turn to something else
i notice the non-muslims here they turn
to music they turn to this they do to
that they they produce something else
and so if you're knitting alongside with
your combat then that's the expression
of your
that's the balance that comes out you
know allah put them
he put a balance in everything and so
that that anger
and that whatever that comes out or that
that raw rar inside of a man i wrote a
whole book about it called a mad monkey
and that's what it's called inside like
like our brother was talking about
you know he said you know he let that
monster out inside yeah that's that mad
monkey every man has one inside
but there's something in you also that
balances it out and if it's knitting
then fine
but you know the brother went skydiving
martial i'd like to see that you know
you slaughter 100 camels put it on your
private website let me see that man
because you know when i've had the
slaughter animals man it was rough okay
later on it got better but you know
that's that's masculine stuff right
there you know it's not easy
these are things that you know they
balance themselves out so let's see it
are we wrapping it up guys or what
what's going on yeah yeah i say we do
wrap it up
yeah i was gonna say one last thing up
here yeah
what what time is it right now it's 10
48.
yeah let's wrap it up let's wrap it up
we said enough yeah
okay
guys thank you so much for tuning in yo
real quick what did you have to say
though
uh
completely forgotten though all right
then uh
i'm gonna do romney's part because
romney's not here statistically speaking
he's probably sleeping through it
because it is pretty early we have to
wake up i woke up like seven eight
um you know just to make you know the
time zone then brother
american lives in germany we got brother
gabriel in malaysia
i'm in toronto he's in florida
but worked out thank you to both of you
brothers for
coming in for this very important psa
um and inshallah until next time
you do this and like your foreplay could
literally consist of nothing but that
y'all could not even have sex and she
would literally
submit to you in every single way even
after the fact
and i i speak that from experience
but um for a lot of purposes if you do
that with your wife
you will see crazy things and if you're
a woman watching this
throw this over to your husband so he
can learn
the game if you're doing it properly and
stuff where she
climaxes even if it's just minor ones uh
multiple times
before you even actually start you know
having the real
intercourse and when you get to that
point you know you're doing it right
what i wanted to add about this whole
foreplay thing
is that a woman has
three stages of orgasm
have an orgasm stage one
all right stage two is orgasm from
penetration or orgasm from
your finger penetrating and hitting the
g-spot
that's like three four or five times
before
penetrating like you really don't have
to go fast at all
you could keep it super slow and just do
exactly what fire was uh showing there
and like you'll probably have a bus
another few times before it's your time
yeah if if you're okay that your beliefs
and your sex life are both in line and
they're both good
you're gonna be fine and that's the kind
of the fundamental the the basis of it
right in that connection
you have the actual you know emotional
connection with your beliefs and
everything being in line you have the
sexual connection with
which is the intimacy being aligned both
are necessary you need them um so focus
on that
and just think about how many things you
didn't know that we just talked about
now
right and i'll think about how much more
there is that you probably don't know
because you grew up in a society where
they don't talk about these things and
they're shunned
they shouldn't be shunned because if
they're shuns then you won't have good
intimacy then your marriage breaks apart
then your family breaks apart and if all
the families in community break apart
the community breaks apart it's not good
it starts here
and with that being said may allah bless
you all and grant us
good spouses and children who will be
the coolness of our eyes and allow us to
be leaders for the righteous people
[Music]
to this day like people who maybe they
would consider
in their definition that i'm their
friend like non-muslims
um because i'm just friendly i
you know will talk to them ask them how
they're doing i'll be concerned like oh
you're sick can i do anything to help
you
i'll be their friend like that but do
am i spending like quality time with
them am i like really
am i like going to tell them my most
vulnerable things like i would with a
close friend like my bff uh no
like the thing is that you like
the people who are really influencing
you are your best friends your closest
inner circle and you want to make sure
that that close
inner circle is good people because
those are the people that you could end
up
being resurrected with like in
yomokiyama when allah is going to raise
you
it's going to raise you with the people
that you love
right the people that you are so close
to
that you love them and you don't want to
be raised
if someone is bad right and you know
that they're doing the wrong thing they
believe the wrong thing
like they are worshipping you know a
man or they're worshiping other gods you
don't want your
afterlife to be tied to that so you have
to be very
practical this is not a joke like we
only get one chance at life
and you don't know if how long you're
going to live tomorrow
you know i might be gone in the next 10
minutes you know i might end this call
with this with you guys and that's it so
i want to make sure
that i'm not taking any chances with my
and
your close friends and the people that
you love
in that way that is a big factor that is
a huge
huge factor so don't gamble with that
[Music]
[Music]
hmm